so boxing you're coming up you're coming
up at 14 you know you're gonna be a
champion during that time whatever's
cuss telling you you're doing it you're
not questioning you you're fully
coachable term you're committed to him
you believe he can help you become a
champion yeah what is your training
during
i'm losing too i'm getting beat i'm
getting knocked out i'm never getting
discouraged though
what does he tell you after you lose
does he talk to you how does he tell you
after you lost like well you know
normally
when i lose i look so spectacular he
said they told me that you're moving
because i'm i have five or six fights
i'm fighting guys with 100 fights with
60 fights and i'm knocking them out and
they're grown men and i'm just 14 years
old so because this guy beat me right by
decision he's 25 years old and cuss came
to me
like um i'm some little baby i'm just
like hey i heard you was too smart for
him but you beat him to the hey i think
i'm in ninth grade
that's my whole life that was the nice
thing he's discussing and destiny
dissertation of what you did this and i
dictated this and it was just all in his
head
by the way the the technical aspect of
boxing did you get that from him or were
you because when you talk boxing like i
know you're a big durant fan you're very
much of a technical guy when it comes to
listen once i'm involved you said i want
to know the beginning of i want to know
where it came from how i was started
who's the first guy that invented it
that's just how my mind works
yeah i've seen you i've seen you train a
couple of the guys you would talk about
footwork you would talk about how to
punch him here how quickly you go below
to go there
and you sound like a mathematician when
you're talking about the art of boxing
yeah i'm
i was born for it
you were born for you were born to fight
nine years old you're bullying 20 year
olds i mean that's pretty impressive
right there i was yeah i was a very
impressive young man i was decided 12
years old everybody thought i was gonna
be tall
wait you were deciding oh this sounds
200 pounds at 12 years old
i would listen
i was fighting the kids that would fight
with fighting their fathers
no i'm serious i would fight their
father i was find their fathers
what do you mean you were fighting their
fathers like i might have passed
somebody and i hit them too hard even
crying went home and got his father and
then you would do the right thing
this is my right hand to god i've been
telling the truth
there's people out here that have been
in that world they know what time it is
they know there's people out there that
are animals they're little babies
because their family were that way if i
had violent family my family was violent
and i'm violent
is it still in you or it's left you hey
when i needed to come back when you
needed a counselor
how many guys watched the roy jones
fight anybody watching roy jones fight
yes or no by the way you look really
good in that fight with i was just happy
that being to be able to entertain
people and i gave a lot to charity
yeah but but mike with all seriousness
like you look like you you could you
hang with a lot of the younger guys
right now that are boxing you don't look
like you were struggling in there
i like to push myself so this time i
tried lennox lewis
you want to go it's linux lewis this
time
and then if this go well
i'm gonna push myself deeper oh
i don't know maybe
it's tyson fury he told me if i keep
winning him i'll do good here boy man i
sent fury yeah that's my buddy no i know
you guys are buddies i've seen he's been
on your podcast you guys have done stuff
together but you'd fight tyson fury
hey i'll fight a lion if the price is
right
when i fight him give me a break would
you literally fight a lion if the price
is right yeah you get in the ring with a
lion cage match with a lion i'm just hey
listen i just can't help it i'm a glory
freak i think yeah
you would fight along anything you know
i raise lines
no of course we know that we watch
hingle
actually i had um five lines around 11
tigers before
you had a white one was it was there a
couple of white couple of white ones
yeah it's what is it with you with lines
tigers and pigeons listen
so listen i'm in prison
i'm talking to my mechanic
and so my mechanic has some of my cars
he's holding my car and he's mad at one
of my friends so he said devonte don't
give me my money back i'ma trade some of
his cars in for some animals like some
horses i said what do you mean you could
trade some you got some animals he said
yeah this guy they had tigers and lions
i said what you mean cubs he said yeah
white tigers and white lions too and so
i'm impressed by the time i get home
from prison i got two lion cubs like two
white um tiger cubs on my lawn
how was it like how big did they get
with you well they got to be 400 pounds
i mean i've seen you walk around when
you were young you sleep with them
you sleep with lions
tigers yeah you prefer tigers over lines
not before lying
so they sleep in your bed
yeah
only one at a time with two in their
fight
that kind of sounds strange what you
just said right there you know
you're vegas when you say things like
that it's yeah no because i was on a one
day i was on one of my
um who was the lady and what's the name
but anyway i was being injured i said i
want to breed her i had babies with her
but they they look like i wanted to
breathe in the way i said i want to
breathe i had babies where they say mike
what do you mean you want a breeder
i i'm not good with words
sleeping next to a tiger when they roll
over did they ever roll over you 400
pounds or what was it like i mean are
they like putting their arms around you
are they
hurrying in the morning control
themselves they control their weight
they know they're balanced they're very
agile
they could know what the tiger you could
do the tigers around full speed ahead
and run up the wall and come back down
in the
seats come back
you want to sleep
no huh and you want to sleep with him
i'm the one that brought him out of his
mother
yeah i want to sleep without him and the
relationship with the pigeons
that i'm curious with the pigeon story
that's just something i've been doing on
my line you're you're entitled to
explain that is that a new york thing is
that a mop thing did you get closer to
the moment because mob always had
pigeons like were you connected to these
gangsters a little bit listen that's
interesting most gang that's a gangster
thing yeah when i went to moscow and i
was like you know the the biggest pigeon
fancier and it was all the mob guys
these guys
the pigeon coops are the biggest this
like houses and they have acres the the
property as far as your eyes can see i'm
saying these are not normal people
yes yes
yeah i don't know what maybe it's a
messenger it's like
maybe it's back in the day so what's
their way of saying
most um um
who's that was noah know what the ark he
had opinions too two of them yeah mommy
let him out and he got the the senior
had opinions too so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]